you better chill
you better
you understand me
you ready to chill
you're gonna
go
stop it stop moving
and when i get off you you're going to
roll over on your stomach you understand
me
by the way turn away from me
thank you
thank you
thank you
your hat
let's go
control atom 590
416 palo verde lunchroom
code four
okay roll towards me and sit on your
butt okay
sit up on your butt all right stand up
we're going straight to the police
office
okay come on man we're going right over
here
okay sit right here for me just relax
what was you guys fighting about
didn't want to talk yet
okay look while we're in here no phones
okay no phones with me
why are you taking my phone
can i get an administrator in the police
office please
all right you cooled out now so if i
take those cuffs off of you you're
chill okay stand up for me
face that wall
what's your name
you calm down
[Applause]
all right please sit back down on that
chair
go ahead and touch where you think it
might be
they hurt everywhere like this
who is it your whole face i don't i
don't actually see any scratches
[Music]
do you have a backpack or anything
here's your hat
so you have a backpack out here yeah
okay what color is it
yeah she already picked it up it both
opened okay who is she your friend no
the administrator this farmer i think i
saw her picking up
papers
all right
all right so what was happening kind of
give me a gist of what was happening
[Music]
any more than this
if you got a full piece of paper
[Applause]
what's your student number
[Music]
so he
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
somebody that has the other party from
the cafeteria 416
call me at 4700 please with his
identification
16 copy
nope gotcha okay so you're by the venue
machine's inside the door correct
he is
approximately you know
before you used the tables on this side
of the
uh-huh
there at wall
okay all right i know what you're
talking about
[Music]
okay
so you're there he's there
he says what to yeah
or did you say something to him first
i said i said what's wrong
you can take this house
did you guys ever actually exchange any
blows or anything like that no okay so
it was just verbal yeah
okay so is your face hurting from me
jumping on you
okay
okay so
then you guys come closer and start
words or
everyone's even close like this how like
do you use it right now really just like
that okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
can you bring a school witness statement
with you please
[Music]
did you have your friends around you i
have two students in my office writing
statement
can you repeat that tracy
hey i have two students in my office
that came up to write today
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
you had a history with this other young
man
i mean have you been talking lately
okay
[Music]
statement with you please you say that
he's got an issue i'll send somebody now
what is this issue thank you what do you
think the issue is
i don't know
um
[Music]
okay all right okay so it's not this
isn't like a summertime thing that's
contained
okay have you been calling him anything
so he okay so he called jesus
and i got stepped here to do it i didn't
even want to take it and make it
yeah
so he's called you this a couple times
in the last few days
a lot of trouble
shoots me
you're not saying anything to him you
just started you guys just started
getting into this today
on monday on monday i did pull him to
the side and i said something to him
and we talked and we squashed it
address of
regal open drive
so obviously before monday
i used to call in your names
and monday kind of had
[Music]
[Music]
okay
okay
well
we never like to have this happen
but at least we didn't have a fight but
here's here's what i want you to do in
the future
if one of us or a police officer hey
we're trying to help you out
okay
have you ever filled one of these out
before
okay
can you put your name do you know his
name
okay just you can just click that's fine
uh location you can talk about what
monday or how long he's been
saying these things about you you want a
table
you can sit at the table i can move
do you know what the other young man
that we had also
was that him
what the other one yeah oh yeah was that
him okay all right so i thought
um i gotta make a phone call because i'm
not sure if i got to do a use of force
on this or not
you need to step out
all right yeah i will just a moment you
need to use this computer for anything
no i don't think so i'm gonna wait here
i'm gonna radio that he is the one other
one involved
did you hear me out here no i'm sorry
here you go okay then your backpack yeah
uh the other one is the other one
involved
layer to it
once we get their statements they can be
released
is in your charger in your pocket still
no
oh
and recording